-Hi! How are you?
-Good. How are you?
-Good.
Congratulations.
Eight seasons of a sketch show
is impossible
with just two people.
And you guys did it,
and the quality never dipped.
Did you change your approach
going into it
knowing this was your last
season as you were writing it?
-We tried not to
because I think, you know,
you go in with the same mission,
which is to make something
that's funny And relatable,
Gets to the heart
of an idea or a character.
And you don't want to be overly
sentimental about something.
-Right.
-'Cause I think that's
a bad place
from which to create,
where you're already
patting yourself on the back
or you're running a victory lap.
Because that's not how
the audience is viewing it.
-No, but I will say,
as an audience member,
I'm also very happy
to see the characters
that we've spent time with
over the last eight years.
The feminist bookstore owners,
Toni and Candace, are back.
Did you --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Was that -- Was it hard
to at least not feel
a little sentimental
when you knew you were playing
characters like that
for the last time?
-I mean, for sure.
And we've noted that the last
time you put on the wigs
or, you know,
with Lance, who's the --
-Yeah, Lance
is a personal favorite of mine,
for those who don't know.
And there's Carrie as Lance.
-Yeah. So...
[ Laughter ]
So, the last time
I wore that mustache.
You know,
and now I have that mustache,
you know,
just on a wall in my house.
-Okay, good.
-That's really disgusting.
Yeah, no.
There was a sadness.
And also sometimes
guests would come on the show,
and they would be
sad in advance.
You know, we would still
be weeks out of finishing,
and they would get emotional.
And so that kind of amplified
our sense of sadness.
So, yeah, the whole thing
has been very bittersweet.
-You directed multiple
episodes this year, yes?
-Mm-hmm.
-Does it -- do you feel --
Is the experience different?
I mean it must be different,
but do you enjoy it more,
being on that side of it?
-I enjoyed --
in the premiere episode,
which is tonight, actually.
A huge portion of that episode,
I'm not in,
which I enjoy,
and I tried to actually
direct the episodes
that are more Fred-focused.
-Right. So that you don't
have to worry about
directing yourself
as a performer.
-Yeah, it's a little tricky.
I lose perspective.
And you have to have
a lot of trust in the process
and in yourself,
and use playback,
and it's just a little clunkier.
So I like when I can just watch
Fred and have some objectivity.
-I feel as though every other
episode, every episode,
you guys make an observation
or you play something
that I can't believe hasn't
happened to the degree
that you guys do it.
You guys played podcasters
in the first episode.
Just delightful.
When you're
in the writer's room,
do you have this moment of, "Oh,
this would be perfect for us
to play a couple
of super-dicky podcasters?"
[ Laughter ]
-I wouldn't say that
that was the exact quote...
[ Laughter ]
...when we started writing it,
but I think we were
talking about how a podcast --
and I am a fan of them...
-I am, too.
-...but they start to get
a little fetishistic, you know,
fetishizing the other.
Like, what would it be like
to live in a rural part
of the country?
-[ Laughs ]
-"Well, I don't know.
A lot of people
live there already.
They could probably tell us."
But, yeah, just elevating
everything to this, you know,
really, like,
intense drama when --
It sometimes feels like they're
creating drama out of nothing.
And so, yeah, we wanted
to explore that lovingly,
so we take over
a police station.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-And it is very lovingly done.
-It is very clear
that you are people
who listen to
and enjoy podcasts, as well.